it's time for the launching horoscope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore watch company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn Jean good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chroma scope mr. William
Bradford Huie and mr. Henry Hazlitt our
distinguished guests for this evening is
the honorable john sherman cooper
senator-elect from Kentucky Senator
Cooper were very happy to welcome you to
Cana scope this evening I'd like to
begin by asking you because of your
experience in the UN whether you think
there's any chance for a truce in Korea
now well as of the moment and
immediately I do not think so this is
always hope but I don't look forward to
any immediate truce I frankly I've never
felt that the Russians
I won't a truce I think their action in
the UN in recent days on the resolution
the Indian resolution is good proof of
that well they're not giving up hope
though John MacArthur says that he
thinks he has a clear and definite
solution of the problem do you think in
view of that that General Eisenhower or
to consult with them now well of course
that's the question for generalizing
there
I would guess that he would give it to
find out what his plan is I think he
would do that I think
well what steps do you think can be
taken to put pressure on the Chinese
Communist to want a truce well I think
you've always got to think of this
Korean question as as part of the the
larger difficulties between Russia and
the rest of the world and that you start
out by knowing it it's a difficult
problem in a very long problem because
we are the real force there I believe
that we have got to have the strength in
Korea which will give the greatest
influence to our position well what are
some of the steps that increase our
strength senator do you think not
knowing myself what the military
dispositions are there
I'm not certain as to what how much
should be added but where to if we're to
convince Russia in Russia primarily that
that they cannot win that they must
adjust the position in Korea that I
think we've got to have the strength
further I certainly favor the
proposition of General Eisenhower that
as quickly as we can we build up the
strength of the South Koreans and then I
would urge strongly that every bit of
influence that we can bring to bear upon
the other members of the United Nations
should be brought to get from them added
military strength at an economic
strength well Senator Cooper our viewers
of course tonight are thinking about the
USS Helena in the Pacific and all of
this meeting it's going on out there
now so first of all why do you think all
of these cabinet members are being
rushed out to see general Osman
and carried aboard by helicopter and so
forth well it's a it's a good operation
well I'm a little melodramatic to you
well no I don't think so I think is very
practical
yeah in the first place everybody is
interested in Korea
he's just been there he's got whatever
information that he could get there and
I think it's with his experience that
that he has got new information and
perhaps much clearer viewpoint
mr. Dulles has been in Washington
conferring with the State Department he
has their views and now they meet
together and as a chance to bring
together those different viewpoints but
from very practical viewpoints I think
they probably be the best opportunity
he'll have until he takes the oath of
office and perhaps for a long time after
that
to get as many of his advisors together
and have the chance to confer without
interruption
well they're talking about other things
besides Korea then I would think so yes
well see what a learn thing one of the
things that makes you interesting drive
yours I'm sure is that your Republican
has just been elected to the Senate down
in Kentucky and I believe that you are
the only Republican that was elected to
the Senate in a state that did not vote
for eisenhower is that correct sir that
is true but it just left a few votes of
voting for eyes and I are out of about a
million votes mr. Stevenson carried
Kentucky by only 700 volts and yet
though Stevenson carried the state you
were elected to the Senate by what was
your majority not 29 thousand votes now
let me ask you this sir why were you
elected to the Senate what did you have
the John
now didn't have in that in Kentucky I'd
like to make it plain that I probably
wouldn't be here on this program it was
generalized and I hadn't been a
candidate that's great why do you think
his gave me the chance but why do you
think you you ran ahead of the ticket in
Kentucky sick is it because you were
well no no I have this it makes the
third race I made for the senator in six
years and of course I they do know me
and I would hope that I was on the
Senate two years and I hope and they
approved of my record there you are then
I was on the ground making a fight all
the time
General Eisenhower came into Kentucky
one day we could have got him back you
two carried Kentucky but for about eight
or nine months I was on the ground every
day making the fight
well now the Republican Party is it
strong in Kentucky and is it a growing
party there little things that questions
are always ask us and you are a
Republican from Kentucky actually miss
Kentucky has a rather strong Republican
Party out of about a million registered
votes we have a registered vote of about
four hundred and twenty five thousand
registered Republicans and we cast it
consistently a good Republican vote
since 1900 we've had five out of the 15
governors but you're about the first
republican has been sent to Congress by
Kentucky in 25 years weren't you in 1946
well in 19 and 46 I was the first one
who'd been elected to Senate to the
Senate and 25 years well coming from a
border state as you do sir and from a
state that has a strong Republican
quarter what do you think of the
Republican Party's chances of making the
south a real two-party system is out and
my state is as you said a border state
and in that category you could class
West Virginia
Lazare Oklahoma and I think even
Tennessee I think that all of those
states those four states have
possibilities to become Republican
states are released to be in a position
where they could turn Republican
majorities much more often and I think
that it's a problem of getting more
honors from the outside from the in
Kentucky and these border states and in
the parties in those states watching
their leadership having good programs
and and doing the best to develop their
own party I think the situation in the
south is different I while our state is
not typically a southern state
politically we have some of the same
problems we have the problem of not
having local and state administration's
which give your continuity what I think
can be done in the south is to take
advantage of the Eisenhower victory to
take into the leadership some of the
Democrats who voted and General
Eisenhower taking that leadership even
more importantly the young people who
came under his banner this year did a
scout right although you were a
Republican you have been serving as a
delegate on the UN haven't you under the
as an appointee of the Truman
administrators are served as a delegate
in 1949 and because of your experience
there I'd like to ask you some questions
about the UN first do you think the in
the United Nations is a success no it's
not a success in the terms that people
had hoped I think it's had a success so
I think it's great success is that it's
it's been an instrument instrument which
has held together the nations who are
members other than the satellite nations
and Russia and kept them pretty
generally upon together
as against Russian domination and
aggression it has is one of its chief
effects been to act as a sounding board
for Russia and propaganda against the
United States
yes it's given Russia a forum it's also
given the United States Great Britain
smaller countries a forum also it is
given the other nations of the world at
least the representatives are there a
chance to see the Russians to hear them
and analyze their propaganda and I think
that's been of definite value well sir
our viewers I'm sure would like to have
your views on what the Republican Party
is likely to do on domestic issues on
January the 20th first of all sir do you
believe that the Republican Party will
reduce taxes I think it will take the
steps which will lead to reduction of
taxes I think reduction of taxes depends
well off on what happens in Korea in
general we'll see you think that the
Republican Party will attempt to repeal
any of the so-called social legislation
that's been built up by the new and fair
deals in detail there may be specific
laws will be repealed in general I think
the general programs of Social Security
of the wage and hour law some labor
legislation when I you tell if you're
copra my will be maintained but they'll
be examined and analyzed when are you
come from a state that has a
considerable labor go do you think that
there'll be more strikes under
Republican administration than they have
been I have the belief that there will
be fewer strikes and I I think we've
already seen some evidence of that since
the election that some strikes are being
sudden the reason I say that is I
believe that when labor knows and
capital as well but I think protects
late labor because I think it's
generally understood
they've had a I think a stronger
advocate that and the merits always
should provide when they know now that
they've got to do what they say they
want to do bargain collectively well
then you're going to have better chances
for agreement well well I'm sorry sir
our time has happened thank you for
being with us thank you very much the
opinions you've heard our speakers
expressed tonight are entirely their own
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching Crona scope was mr.
William Bradford GUI and mr. Henry
Hazlitt our distinguished guests was the
honorable john sherman cooper
senator-elect from kentucky
under any Christmas tree it's the little
packages which intrigue what can it be
we say and this Christmas many hope that
in one like this there'll be a launching
the world's most honored watch truly
throughout the world no other name on a
Christmas watch means so much as the
name Longy in the whole world there are
a few watches to equal long gene and
quality and none of such great renown
among the finest watches of the world
launching alone has won 10 world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medal
awards and so many honors for accuracy
now if this Christmas you wish to give
the gift of great prestige why not alone
gene every long gene watch is
superlative in styling superb in finish
unsurpassed for faithful timekeeping yet
unbelievably you may buy and proudly
give a long gene watch this Christmas
for as little as seventy one fifty
launching the world's most honored watch
the world's most honored Christmas gift
premier product of the laun jean wit nor
watch company since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest
character we invite you to join us every
monday wednesday and friday evening at
the same time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored long Jean
this is David Ross speaking for your
regular host frank night reminding you
that lon Jean and wit nor watchers are
sold and serviced from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
who proudly display this emblem agency
for long Jean wit nor watches
it's time for the launching promise Co a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour a presentation of the
laun gene which snore what's company
maker of launching the world's most
honored watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honoured laun
gene good evening this is David Ross
speaking for your regular host Frank
Knight may I introduce our co-editors
for this edition of the launching
promise Co mr. William Bradford Huie
editor of the american mercury and mr.
Henry Hazlitt contributing editor of
Newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
Herbert R O'Connor senator from Maryland
senator I'm very happy to welcome you to
Chronicle this evening as you're a
member of the Senate Internal Security
Committee I'd like to begin by asking
you what your impression is of this
three-man panel report that was turned
in by the United Nations for the United
Nations to Secretary General Lee and
this has that I'm I approve of the
conclusions reached by the International
Juris these three distinguished
attorneys have done a comprehensive job
I regret that it was necessary really to
invoke their aid because the questions
presented seem to us to be very clear
and that is that subversives those
individuals of American citizen rate who
are disposed to work against the inners
of the United States we feel ought never
to have been employed in the United
Nations and the fact that tonight some
15 of them are either under suspension
or have been separated from the service
indicates that there was very much to be
done
I do think that the conclusions reached
by the International Panel are to be
approved well there were several
important conclusions they
the first one an important seems to me
that anybody who was an active member of
the Communist Party could be dismissed I
assume that you agree with that
thoroughly
wholeheartedly and then there was
another another recommendation that
anybody who had who admitted that he had
been server civ in the past could be
suspended until his record was looked
into I think some you agree with that
that is corrected and third and I
thought quite an important one and view
of the public confusion on the point was
this that anybody who refused to testify
on the ground that it might incriminate
him could be dismissed and should be
dismissed on the ground that he had
created a suspicion of guilt by his
refusal to answer now do you agree with
that final point I do miss hazard but I
would like to just add another word or
two in respect to that our principal
difficulty in the hearings up until this
very day has been that many of our
people of our citizens labor under a
misapprehension they feel that having
secured a position with an international
organization that they are beyond the
reach of a regularly constituted agency
of the federal government inquiring into
their actions not as United Nations
members not in relation to the
particular work but prior to their
association with the organization or
outside of the scope of that work and we
of course have been definitely of the
belief that the Senate committee has a
right to inquire into their affiliation
with the Communist Party for example or
their engagement in subversive
activities and when they decline to
answer on the ground that to answer
would tend to incriminate them we feel
that that puts them under suspicion to
such an extent that they are not
suitable persons to be in the secretary
act of the United Nations
sir to clarify just a bit and many of
our viewers I'm sure feel that your
committee is deliberately harassing the
United Nations number one the committee
is is the macaron committee it is the
Bacardi committee a regularly
constituted subcommittee of the Senate
chair holding hearings in New York and
and who are your colleagues on that
committee sir
well senator McCarran of Nevada senator
Ferguson of Michigan senator Watkins
senator Jenner senator Willis Smith the
former president of the American Bar
Association's at our East End of
Mississippi and myself now have you
found evidence that they are communists
employed American communists employed by
the United Nations definitely and it's
and it's your position that you you have
a right to to investigate these people
and to expose them not only a right but
a duty
now are you a supporter of the United
Nations sir yes I'd like to just amplify
on that a bit I am NOT one who believes
that just because these little problems
have arisen possibly not so little but
definitely problems that that is a
reason for the abolition of the United
Nations as such I do not think that you
don't think it would be necessary to
burn down a bond to get rid of the rest
I do not think so I feel that the
objectives of the UN are so important in
this critical period that we should give
support to the UN and we believe that
ultimately our action will restore the
confidence of the American people which
I'm regret to say we felt was being
shaken when revelations were brought out
that communists people who had been
discharged from departments in
Washington for their doubtful loyalty
are found in the Secretariat of the
United Nations you think this is an
anomalous situation created here senator
now my understanding of this committee
report this panel report was that Lee
the secretary-general could fire any
member of a non communist nation who was
guilty of being a communist but that he
couldn't fire a car
of course from a communist nation now
doesn't that create a very anomalous
position within the United Nations it
does and in all fairness to bits at
Rigby Lee I feel that the responsibility
has not been his or the fault if any has
not been his because I think he has made
a genuine effort to discharge his
responsibilities and at the same time to
retain the status of the UN as it was
originally conceived it is of course an
international organization its
Secretariat is not supposed to be under
dictation from any member nation and
consequently he has had to chart a
course which would be between that of
giving recognition to the rights of the
United States for example as against the
communist countries doesn't the very
fact that we have communist nations as
members of the organization make the
organization either ineffective or
effective as a sounding board for
communist exactly so and it is to be
expected that with the international
organization including communist nations
that of necessity their representatives
in the Secretariat will be sympathizers
with their particular government what do
you think Russia should keep the veto
power that at present has well I think
of course that there are reasons on both
sides I do not think of course that it
should be carried to the extent that it
has because I in a way it demonstrates
the fact that Russia is not sincere in
their in their efforts to achieve the
objectives of the UN that I senator is
this a fair statement sir
that our keeping the United Nations in
New York allowing it to meet here that
is a calculated risk on the part of our
nation
it is and it calls for this this one
extra consideration I think as the host
nation the United States is within its
rights in demanding that extra
precautions be taken to guard the
internal security of the United States
moving on from the United Nations sir I
believe your committee found a rather
interesting case of communism in the
inside the armed services did it yes
that was in the thin the lieutenant
Thurman case in a very disgraceful one
and and you found that an officer in the
Army was actually in charge of prisoners
on Coney Island but actually he has been
commissioned he's still in the army
although he's under observation by the
the military authorities he had been
commissioned had gone to Koshien had
actually been in charge to forty now
that your committee 40,000 40,000
prisoners of war now that now that your
committee is called attention to that
situation do you think that it's being
corrected well I certainly think it
ought to be and I have enough confidence
in the in the Secretary of Defense of
the entire military establishment to
believe that they are going to the to
the bottom of this issue or at the
circumstances rather remarkable under
which he was taken in the engine he
refused to answer some question of
importance yes in the application for
Commission in answer the questions as to
whether he is or has been a member of
subversive organization he declined to
answer that don't constitutional ground
well he was nonetheless accepted he was
nonetheless accepted and senator we
can't our viewers I know wouldn't want
you to leave without recalling the fact
that you were part of the Kefauver
investigation now after looking back in
retrospect only ketover activities do
you think that that was useful for the
country
I think highly useful yes yes yeah you
were you were one of those I think that
made mr. O'Dwyer enjoy the climate down
in Mexico well at least he has sojourned
there for the period since that time
what what do you think about the
situation as far as crime in our cities
now do you think that it's still one
that that calls for investigation oh I
think undoubtedly so I I do not think
the work of any one committee in a
limited time would clear up the very
unfortunate situation that has existed
in America in the large metropolitan
areas particularly and and since you are
not to be a member of the new Congress
sir is it your opinion that the new
Congress should continue such an
investigation I think there are many
things to be said in favor of some
periodic check whether it would be of a
committee set up as the Kefauver
committee was or whether it would be a
one that would give just a review of
conditions in the country as well well
thank you very much for being with us
this evening the opinions you've heard
our speakers expressed tonight are
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the launching Crona
scope was mr. William Bradford Huie
and mr. Henry Hazlitt our distinguished
guests was the honorable Herbert R
O'Connor senator from Maryland
the problem of selecting a Christmas
gift of great prestige for someone near
and dear is most happily solved with a
lawn gene watch discriminating men and
women appreciate the elegance of lawn
gene watches they're greater accuracy
their faithfulness and world honors
confirm their judgment for among the
world's finest watches long gene watches
alone have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medal awards
and highest honors for accuracy from
government observatories yes the problem
of selecting a Christmas gift of great
prestige for someone near and dear is
indeed most happily solved with a lawn
gene watch yet you may buy and proudly
give a lawn gene watch this Christmas
for as little as seventy one fifty and
may I add if you pay
7150 or more for a watch you are paying
the price of a lawn gene and you should
insist on getting a launching the
world's most honored watch the world's
most honored Christmas gift premier
product of the lawn gene wit nor watch
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
we invite you to join us for the long
gene Cronus cope a television journal of
important issues of the hour broadcast
on behalf of launching the world's most
honored watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honoured Longy
this is David Ross speaking for your
regular host frank night reminding you
that wrong gene and wit nor watches are
sold and serviced from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
who proudly display this emblem agency
for launching with nor waters
you
honored murdered wahed wahed wahed is
gone gone gene watches have won ten
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and more honors for accuracy
than any other type EES launching the
world's most honored watch is made and
guaranteed by the lawn gene with no
watch company
it's time for the long gene horoscope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the long gene wit nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch can wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honoured long gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching promise co mr. Bruno Shah
author editor and commentator and mr.
William Bradford Huie
editor of the american mercury our
distinguished guests for this evening is
the honorable homer ferguson united
states senator from michigan in this
spontaneous and unrehearsed discussion
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers the ferguson our
audience of course knows you as a
one-man crime Buster in Detroit and as a
distinguished member of the Senate
specifically sir just what are your
committee assignments at the moment I'm
a member of the Judiciary Committee and
also of the policy committee and the
Appropriations Committee mr. Huey and
the Judiciary Committee the subcommittee
of course is concerned with security at
the moment isn't it yes there's a
subcommittee of that committee which
in the internal security that Gish's
that committee is concerned with the
president's current effort to enforce
stricter censorship on the american
press i believe yes it is concerned with
that and what has been your position sir
have you opposed the president's efforts
to make censorship stricter on the press
yes I have opposed that and the reason
that I have proposed it listed here is
that I believe that in a republic such
as our that we must have freedom of the
press freedom of thought freedom of
speech one of the very fundamentals that
we must have are those freedoms and of
course the danger is this that a weak
government uses the weapon of censorship
well how conceal how far would you carry
that senator
how would you carry in the field of
national defense how free could you be
with publication of news and national
defense of course I'm a firm believer
I've stated on the Senate floor that I
believe in the security and there are
certain things in the national defense
that they should determine whether or
not it's for our security you can't wear
on your cuffs all of the secrets of the
national military establishment if the
reconstruction Finance Committee sir
could have decided what information
could properly be published in the
United States we probably would not have
had some of the recent revelations would
we you wouldn't have had any of it and
as I say a weak government goes to the
censorship to attempt to keep things
from the public take the order after the
president issue
let's give good faith to his issuing it
on the question of security but he was
delegating to each one of his men in the
various departments and agency the right
to determine on their own what was to be
secured in the o-p-s but one in anything
that might
embarrassing to them wouldn't you say
that he might have a more reasonable
approach to it and that the people would
accept it with greater reason if he if
he issued such an order together with
the press with a selected group of the
press to discuss it and to were to
express their judgement on these various
kinds of orders including military
censorship oh there's no doubt about
that
mr. Shah you should have taken the press
in discuss the whole matter and first if
there were sufficient causes had a
voluntary censorship and then if there
were couldn't go to rely on the
voluntary one then he should have used
the next as a real censorship on
security senator I believe that you're
the McCarran subcommittee at which you
are a member has also been considering
the matter of the Institute of public
relations and particularly a
controversial figure mr. Jessop now what
are your views in the Jessup case well I
I would say this and I'm not going to
draw any judgments tonight because we
have not finished those mr. Dooley the
hearings are going on and my work on the
bench has always taught me to low whole
judgment till the last sentence is in
the record but I'll say this that so far
the record discloses that there was a
penetration in the Institute of Pacific
relations of those who at least were
giving aid and comfort to the Communist
lon you have heard senator Diaz have
heard former governor staffs and I
believe before yourselves he was that
even there today he were feared before
the committee I'd like to ask one
question all night wouldn't you say that
since mr. Jessup himself said he was a
member of the America first committee
and other very let's say right-wing
organizations that it's somewhat
incompatible for him to be charged with
both that and
in affiliation but wouldn't you say that
regardless of what he's charged whether
he's got pretty near 100% wreck in a bad
judgment well I don't want to say it's a
hundred percent that that's going a
little far on any man's judgment we all
make mistakes but I think there is some
evidence in the record that some of
these judgments were very poor now as it
was any doubt about that our audience of
course knows you as the colleague of the
late Senator Vandenberg and his memoirs
I understand are about to be published
do you think that they likely to shed
any light on this particular controversy
they'll they'll shed some light on
February the 5th they'll shed the light
that there was a meeting in the White
House and the question of 1940 1949 of
furnishing military aid were the
stopping of the aid to the Nationals
government in China the committee in the
next few days will receive the copy of
the page of the senator's diary that he
wrote with his own typewriter and you
think the Vandenberg revelation will be
damaging to the cause of mr. Jessup and
will support mr. Stassen and the
controversy well I think it supports the
contention of mr. Stasi that the State
Department mr. Atchison was perfectly
willing to have the aid stopped as of
that time and that Senator Vandenberg
was only consulted on the China policy
as I understand it on that particular
occasion was that their senator was that
committee I think of about 20 to 25 it
was had a pretty well-balanced committee
picnic well they the committee that went
that's another committee on in October
of nineteen hundred and forty-nine
that's the committee that mr. Stassen is
talking about that's the one that he can
tens that the record now shows and they
have finally produced the record showing
that the sympathy was on the side of the
recognition of Red China was that a
well-balanced committee would you say
you know by I think no the reason we're
investigating that particular committee
was that there's so many members of it
were members of the Institute of Pacific
relation which we are investigating as
to whether or not there was penetration
by the Communists or the communist line
to some that point up there do you
expect to oppose the appointment that
mr. Jessop to the ambassador of post
he's recommended for I would say at the
present time from what I can learn from
the committee hearings that I should be
compelled to vote against the
confirmation of mr. Jessup for this
particular post our I try to reserve
judgment as long as possible on these
matters and I I want to hear all the
evidence but that's the way I would
stand tonight know what a frank we say
that our audience also knows that you
have to do with taxes and and money is
there since you're an important member
of the Appropriations Committee now this
morning we notice that we have 11
percent tax increase
did you favor that tax increase sir mr.
Huey I voted against that tax bill I
came to the conclusions and my
conscience really rebelled that I could
not vote for it because I felt that we
were placing a burden on the American
people that could be avoided by the
cutting of expenses in government and I
sincerely believe that that was true
have you got a have you any idea at all
of what that cut could amount to in
comparison with all the other things
that you're probably in favor of which
is Nash huge national defense point for
Marshall Plan and all the others is it
really is a billion amount that the
is considerable or is it just a matter
of principle to cut it out no it isn't I
believe that we could have taken six to
eight billions of dollars I hesitate
mentioning billions of dollars because
it's such an enormous sum that is very
difficult to understand I like to
explain a billion as being one-tenth of
the entire production of metropolitan
Detroit of all the industries for a year
because they produce about 10 billion
dollars worth so you can see how much
goods that is with the amount of
automobiles and everything else that's
produced in that great metropolitan area
senator I'm sure that our audience
wouldn't want you to leave before you
gave us a prediction as to whether you
think taxes will go even higher in
America well I don't see how they can go
much higher and my reason for saying
that just about three weeks ago I met
with members of the House and members of
the Senate and we were discussing this
tax question and they came to the
conclusion that we are about at the
bottom of the barrel some of them think
we are through the bottom and there are
no other greater sources to actually get
returns without diminishing returns that
is that you tax people so much that they
business goes down and there is a
failure to get taxes rather than to get
more I see so some of you you believe as
a member of the Appropriations Committee
that we have reached the point of
diminishing returns thank you very much
for being with us tonight sir
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching Khurana scope was mr.
Bruno Shah and mr. William Bradford Huie
our distinguished guests was the
honorable Homer Ferguson United States
senator from Michigan a watchmaker such
as lon Jean recalls that Christopher
Columbus made his great voyages before
the watch was invented
his only timepiece was a San Blas like
this rare specimen from the Hayden
Planetarium this was reversed every
half-hour the ours on shipboard were the
seven hours of Prayer in those days the
only navigating instrument was a compass
and so navigators of today salute
Columbus as the peer of them all
Columbus Day marks a long gene milestone
for one of the 38 World's Fair awards
won by long Jean was this gold medal of
the San Luis Columbia exposition some
fifty nine years ago the 400th
anniversary of the discovery of America
which honored Christopher Columbus now
consider how consistently launching
watches have maintained their leadership
over the years winner of first prizes
for more than three-quarters of century
including ten world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals and literally
thousands of awards for accuracy from
the great government observatories
today's lone gene watches are our finest
distinguished for exclusive styling
endowed with traditional accuracy and
long life truly throughout the world no
other name on a watch means so much as
launching the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the lawn Jean with
nor watch company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
this is Frank Knight again reminding you
that the lone gene chrono scope is
brought to you three times weekly every
Monday Wednesday and Friday so won't you
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at this same time for the
long gene Cronus code a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored long gene sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display the emblem agency for long Jean
wit nor Watson
leave honored murdered wha-wha-wha is
long gone Jean watches have won 10
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and more honors for accuracy
than any other timepiece launching the
world's most honored watch is made and
guaranteed by the laun Jean with no
watch company it's time for the
launching promise Co a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour brought show you every Monday
Wednesday and Friday a presentation of
the lon gene which snore what's company
maker of launching the world's most
honored watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lawn Jean
good evening this is frank night may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching Chronos code
mr. Edgar Baker a managing director of
time-life international and mr. Henry
Hazlitt editor of the freeman and
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable Hubert H
Humphrey United States Senator from
Minnesota the opinions discussed are
necessarily those of the speakers well
senator Humphrey I see that the New York
Times this morning credits you with a
very important victory in helping to get
past the president's reorganization plan
of the Internal Revenue Bureau at the
times wrote the victory was less a
personal one for the president than it
was for three freshman senators who led
the fight Hubert Humphrey of Minnesota
Mike Mulroney of Oklahoma and Blair
moody of Michigan so could you begin by
telling us what the reorganization plan
does senator well they key to the
reorganization plan or the crux of it is
that it removes the political patronage
system from the office of the collector
of Internal Revenue in other words it
places the appointment of all the
collectors of Internal Revenue in the
many revenue districts strictly under
the civil service system the competitive
merit examination I think this is highly
desirable I think that we have had
plenty of demonstration of the
inadequacy of the politically appointed
collectors of Internal Revenue it places
a premium upon competence and technical
background
well senator of my memory is correct of
the sixty-four present collectors as
seventh leader been forced to resign or
discharged now doesn't that mean that
the president's plan is an effective
plan to prevent himself from making bad
appointments well as a matter of fact
the President Truman made one of the
appointments he or said either he or
Fresno's well I meant to for any
president because may I say that back in
the good old days the days when Andrew
Mellon was secretary of the Treasury we
had an even worse situation and we had
now I don't mean to inject the
partisanship into it but it's literally
true there these are not holdovers from
the Mellon that they're not whole
dollars but the political patronage
system just has not produced the kind of
caliber and talent that we should have
and in offices as important as the
collector of Internal Revenue Office
plus the fact that they present
collectors offices a busy office you
have over seventy million tax returns
for example about fifty million
taxpayers and when you consider the
tremendous number of taxes that a
collector of Internal Revenue must be
responsible for I think he ought to be
recruited and hired on the basis of
technical skill background experience
and all that comes with a competitive
merit system examination
well senator the the passage of the bill
is very timely the idea of March the
final date for tax payment or closed
upon us I understand that you are in
favor of an even tighter tax bill is
that correct I'm in favor of what I call
a tighter or a more honorable tax
structure that is absolutely true I
personally believe that the entire tax
structure of our country needs a basic
overhauling it has grown pretty much
like Topsy every time we've needed a
little more revenue we've fished around
to find some new way of adding a new tax
to the tax structure in the meantime
some people have been fishing around to
see how they could get out of paying
taxes senator what specific
recommendations would you make
well my recommendations have been turned
not by myself alone but by many others
over the years loophole plugging
provisions by that I mean tightening up
the tax structure and Rep
to certain specific tax allowances or
tax special treatment taxes that we have
in the tax system such as the capital
gains tax structure family partnerships
the failure to have withholding upon
corporate bond interest and dividends
the split income provisions the
depletion allowances for gas and oil
wells there are other such little tax
matters as corporate spin oil Senator
suppose we take the first one you've
mentioned the carrion game tax yes would
you do about that what's your
recommendation on that well first of all
I want to make my position quite clear I
think that the capital gains tax
schedule which is to be differentiated
from the Earned Income schedule and the
corporate income schedule is a
legitimate tax schedule I mean it has a
legitimate purpose the purpose for us
when it was enacted was to promote
investment capital improvement and
investment the original capital gains
was for 25% tax maximum of 25 percent
but you had to hold your property or
your bond or your stock for a period of
two years to give a sense of legitimacy
to the investment now that period that
holding period has been reduced from two
years to one year to 6 months and in the
last two sessions of the Congress
they've tried to cut it down to three
months when speculation has been rampant
particularly by the way every time you
have a defense or a war situation they
always want to cut down the holding
period on capital gains
well senator isn't it true that on the
other side you cannot deduct capital
losses against income you can Deedle
except except against about $3,000 so
capital losses are not deductible
therefore you can't shouldn't tax
capital gains as full income should you
mr. haslund I'm sure that you and I'll
have quite a disagreement about that
because when you talk about capital
gains and capital losses you can deduct
capital losses from your capital gain
capital gains but not again in the same
house yes I have to add your capital
gains tax to your income tax but you
cannot deduct your capital losses from
your income that's a director's I'll
wait a minute isn't that a
I win tails you lose no what you have is
and the government loses and tails you I
am sorry if the head of the government
wins that the tails you lose you the
taxpayer loses because you can't adopt
it against her income now that's the
simple fact Senate mr. Haslett thereon
everywhere are subtle it's a poll and
you're a wise economist and you know
that there are three basic tax
structures in this country the kind I
pay which is earned income tax the time
that a corporation pays which is
corporate tax and the kind that a
speculator pays which is capital gains
tax and the guy that's speculating on
the market pays a lower tax rate than a
worker that's earning $7,500 a year
short-term gain on a subtler gain no
nuts degree more games he pays the same
as a Mystics much gain at the whole that
is not considered a short-term waiver
speculated that used to be your sweet
choir caps at around six yet used to
require two years for capital gains what
I am saying mr. Haslett is that if you
lose in the capital gains market you can
be you can deduct your losses from your
capital gains and you only pay twenty
forty five percent under the present law
upon your earning but you leave all
revenues if I lose as a wage earner
if I lose as a wage earner one year I
cannot go back and deduct it from my
taxes that I paid the other year but you
don't Humphrey that that's an area in
which in which I believe both are all
three sides of the of the of the
argument are agreed that whatever change
might be made would be comparatively
moderate there's another area you
mentioned earlier the earlier the phrase
depletion allowance one that we hear a
great deal of that would you would you
care to explain and in general terms
what the principle of the depletion
allowance is yes I give a little
historical background on the depletion
allowance say it was enacted in the
Congress I believe in the year nineteen
twenty-five or twenty-six right around
that period and the purpose of the
depletion allowance for gas and oil and
some mining interests like sulfur Birds
and now that extended further to have
been extended to about forty five
commodities and by the way that's that's
another one of the tricks we even got it
on Easter shells now a depletion
allowance it's been extended by home
senator by the Congress by the Congress
over the objections of the executive
every time a special interest group sand
and gravel boys want to get in on it
last time well what is it is a kid to
have a depletion allowance when there's
real depletion no I think a depletion
allowance that's fair and equitable
in terms of the scientific technical the
technology of the day is legitimate now
the purpose of the depletion allowance
at first was to promote exploration of
oil and gas fields so we had a depletion
allowance of twenty seven and a half
percent but since that time a I say the
scientific knowledge of where a gas
field is and where an oil field is is
much better than it was in 1925
but isn't it also true sounder okay I
decide yet that they actually know how
much oil is under the ground no not in
every instance and they don't know how
much they're depleting it to that mr.
Haslett a man in business gets what he
calls a depreciation allowance if you
have only $1000 AG about initiated yes
now a depletion allowance is a twenty
seven and a half percent upon your gross
revenue so defining it in three years
and that would be right at you a likely
that they're gonna pay to get in longer
plus the fact plus the fact that a man
that drills an oil well and finds a dead
hole when he finally hits one he can
take all of the deductions for all of
the losses that he had before but
senators ninety-five separate gratuities
or benefits given by the government for
mining and gas and oil development o fi
what you didn't have in 1925 and I say
that it's absolutely wrong in the year
1952 to have a depletion allowance of
twenty-seven and a half percent on gross
income when you have forty five special
benefits today but you didn't have at
the time that the law was enacted first
the tremendous change in a great many
respects between 1925 in 1952 however
insofar as the supply of oil and other
critical raw materials are concerned
that's correct
the supply is even the no.1 supply today
is much greater than it was in 1995 and
they write a bond market for gas and oil
wells are gilt-edged securities and the
profit percentage in gas and oil
development is above any other commodity
in the American market well senator has
a last question is a final question do
you think that there is a prospect in
the near future of a reduction of taxes
generally or do you think the prospect
is for higher taxes well I think it
greatly depends upon the international
situation and I think the American
people must know that the hi schedule of
tax today is primarily the result of the
great international crisis it is my
feeling that as we level off and paper
off on our rearmament program that we
can get these taxes down and
I think they should come down the earned
income tax and the corporate tax are
terribly high they're very high and it's
for that reason that I say that we
should plug up these special treatment
areas and thereby be able to at least
level off the earned income tax rate and
the corporate tax rate so that you don't
knock out incentive in business and that
you do not place an undue burden upon
the individual that is having a pretty
tough time making it go in this inflated
period
well senator thank you very much for
your answers they've been very
illuminating and we appreciate very much
your being with us tonight
thank you the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Crona scope was
mr. Edgar Baker and mr. Henry Hazlitt
our distinguished guests was the
honorable Hubert H Humphrey United
States senator from Minnesota
the Winter Olympic Games recently
completed at Oslo in Norway were
exclusively timed by long gene to a
tenth and a hundredth of a second this
telegram that I have here is our reward
lon gene equipment used for all
timekeeping during the Winter Olympic
Games 1952 all worked perfectly thanks
for your valuable cooperation and it
signed the organizing committee now
that's a wonderful telegram and we're
ever so pleased
launching was actually official watch
for the three great Olympic sports
events during the past year the Winter
Olympics at Oslo the third Bolivarian
games at Caracas and Venezuela and the
first Pan American Games held in Buenos
Aires in Argentina and now we are proud
to announce that the United States
Olympic Committee has selected lon Jean
watches for timing all events for the
selection of the United States Olympic
team of 1952
so you see wherever precise timing is
important in sports aviation and science
as in everyday life the preeminent
choice of watches is long Jean the only
watch in history to win 10 world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medals
and highest honors for accuracy from the
leading government observatories long
Jean the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the laun jean wit
nor watch company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene Khurana scope the
television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wet nor distinguished
companion to the world on our lawn gene
this is frank night reminding you again
that long gene and wit nor watches are
sold and serviced by more than four
thousand leading jewelers from coast to
coast who proudly display this emblem
agency for long Jean wit nor Watson
it's time for the launching Chronister a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Cronus cope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. robert d Colburn an
editor of Businessweek magazine our
distinguished guest for this evening is
the honorable Irving M Ives United
States Senator from New York senator
eyes it's a pleasure to have you again
on the krona scope tonight sir and
earlier this week we have had mister
Franklin Roosevelt jr. and mr. Averell
Harriman who have summed up the issues
for our viewers and tonight sir because
we are not on will not be on the air
Monday night because of the large wind F
programs
tonight is our last program before the
election and we'd like for you to sum up
for the Republicans just as mr.
Roosevelt and mr. Harriman have done to
the Democrats now sir a great deal of
emphasis has been put on the Korean
issue in these last few days of the
campaign and our Democratic spokesmen
have accused General Eisenhower of being
a little unfair in injecting the issue
that he would go to Korea now number one
sir do you think that it has been an
unfair tactic on the part of generalized
but surely I certainly do not and at the
same time how to tell you how much I
appreciate being on this program again I
think the general Eisenhower in
undertaking a trip of that kind is doing
exactly what he should do he is a
military man one of the greatest
generals we've had in all time this
country do you think it's primarily a
military problem I do not I think it's
political also but I think it's both
military and political and I think the
general probably could get more out of
it by going over there than almost
anybody else in this country who would
not be acquainted with it at firsthand
would that be primarily an information
gathering I would assume that's what he
intends to find out what is being done
over there how the equipment is how the
supplies are how the men are with morale
is at firsthand because of course he's
had this tremendous experience as two
people have had and he can understand
that you do you think that that the
general eisenhower would have a better
chance of settling the korean conflict
than governor stevenson well I certainly
do and one of the things that General
Eisenhower injected was the fact that he
would step up the training of South
Koreans with the hope that he could
relieve our own troops of bearing the
brunt of the of the frontline battle and
for that he was accused of some
dishonesty now sir do you think that a
general Eisenhower has a valid point
there well I think general Van fleets
letter that was written indicating that
he had done the tea general Van Fleet
had done all that he can do or could do
within his capacity within his ability
within the limit of the supplies and
equipment and all that's concerned there
would permit indicated that more can be
done and the fact that gentlemen fleet
now has said or stated as I understand
that more can be done if he had more
equipment he'd be able to do more more
supplies he'd be able to do more it
shows that General Eisenhower was
absolutely justified this yes what would
you think would be a reason that tariffs
necessary supplies and such would be
with Harold yeah why would there may be
against training more Koreans
if it were practical I haven't the
answer to that question I don't know
what the answer is I haven't seen any
official statement made on the subject
from any source that is competent to
offer such a statement I can't see what
it would be I can't understand why we
shouldn't I don't know I I'm I'm utterly
tired sick and tired of this whole
Korean tragedy and I think the sooner we
get the South Koreans in a condition
where they can hold the frontlines as
far as they're able to hold them the
better off for all of us UN and
ourselves can include it and why the
South Koreans haven't been placed in a
condition where they can occupy those
front lines I don't know I haven't seen
any excuse of any kind offered for that
well sir you think that general
Eisenhower's suggestion that we use more
Asians to fight Asians is a is a sounds
that is the fundamental idea on which we
were supposed to operate in the Orient
from the beginning we've always
understood in this country that if we
are going to fight any part of Asia
mainland of Asia we should not do it
with the troops of the Western powers
then a very fact that our Western troops
are doing the fighting automatically
gives the gifts to our action a wrong
impression where the those against whom
we're fighting or at least those who may
be new to over in that area are
concerned they look upon it as a Western
invasion you think your Asian power the
Kim deal with the Chinese do I think
what there is any Asian power the can
deal with the Chinese well yes I think
you I think your South Koreans properly
trained can deal with them in so far as
possible insofar as their numbers have
permit their 20 million people in South
Korea I don't know why they can't
provide enough troops to hold them for a
while move as a matter of fact we've got
to bring this South Korean thing to a
termination one of these days I
understand that these people let's say
that this is only a peninsula it's not a
part of the mainland of Asia insist that
we're not in a mainland war but I insist
we are on Asia Korea is a peninsula yes
but we're on we're on Egypt part of Asia
it's not an island and we've always have
been led to believe and I know
and why it isn't true that if we ever
get into a main land war in Asia we're
going to be bled white and that can very
easily happen in Korea our casualties
now running as you know over a thousand
a week well sir now moving on to what's
generally regarded as the second big
issue and sort of summing up what's been
said about communists in government do
you think that General Eisenhower has
been on sound ground there or that
there's been anything unfair in his
approach to that issue nothing unfair
that I know of whatever the whole record
has indicated that the generals position
is absolutely sound absolutely
vindicated in terms of your particular
interest senator the FPPC question is
one of the is a major issue to miss Kay
well I think I think you determine FPPC
I use a broader term I think it's a
question of civil rights I think that's
one of the fundamentally vital questions
today I believe thoroughly that we've
got to begin to practice what we preach
in this country and if we mean what we
say and what we profess to believe it's
high time we begin to carry out our
configure you're the author of city of
New York state legislation on that
subject I am I'm the Atlantic co-author
of the I so-called I've spin law I'm the
eyes in the deal how do you feel that
your own views on that matter are in
accord with the views of the platform of
the Republican national platform that
other the national platform which was
created there in talking about now the
plank on civil rights I assume that
flank is created in such broad terms
that we can push ahead for a a federal
fep see if you desire to call it that
with enforcement provisions at any time
that we can possibly get a chance to go
ahead with it there's nothing in our
platform which prohibits anything of the
kind in fact it's left wide open
actually who anticipate such a lot it
isn't is out if you don't mind because
this is important actually during the
course of that convention and during the
course of the committee action on the
matter in the convention a proposition
to limit Fe PC activities to the level
of the states and not to permit it on
the federal level was defeated in
committee by a vote of 39 to 30
demonstrating definitely that the
position
by the Republican platform committee
their resolutions committee was
definitely opposed to limiting Effie PC
operations to the state level and
thereby leaving the door wide open for
the federal approach well now those
those of our viewers who are concerned
with civil liberties civil rights and
who want during the next four years to
see more and more done in that direction
do you think that they can safely go
with the Republicans in 1952
well I can't rely upon mr. Yeo they can
have any hope of getting anything done
through the Democrats I mean the very
idea back of that is utterly ridiculous
because the history of civil rights at
least during the last twenty years shows
that the Republicans from the standpoint
of the filibuster and the attempt to get
cloture from the standpoint of activity
in behalf of the legislation itself and
from the standpoint of the record all
the way through the Republicans have
done far more in favor of civil rights
the legislative standpoint then have the
Democrats in that same period I want one
of the details of that because it's
rather long exhaustive but actually if
the Republicans have done just about
twenty times as much in the Senate if
the Republicans control Congress next
year would you expect that some civil
rights legislation would pass no you
can't pass civil rights legislation but
we can conquer the filibuster that's our
first hurdle that we have to make and
that's the best where the drive should
be made directly on getting a cloture
provision rule 22 of this call changed
in such a way that we can put a limit or
stop to the filibuster by a majority
vote of the members of the Senate when
that's done then we can go ahead with
civil rights legislation and that's
going to be a big hurdle to get over and
we've got to get over and we've got to
use every ounce of energy we have in
that attempt moving to the other big
issue sir a labor legislation many of
our viewers of course are interested in
labor legislation and I believe that
that mr. Stevenson has promised to
repeal the taft-hartley act out right
now what can you say on that subject sir
in something we're talking about mr.
Stevenson's position I just didn't start
with that because as I recall mr.
Stevenson's position prior to his
nomination was not in favor repealed he
was opposed to repeal to the
taft-hartley Act
and in favor of its amendment the minute
he got the nomination or immediately
thereafter almost he changed his
position came out for repeal of the Act
well now let me just point out what
repeal amounts to is compared to
amendment the only thing that one gains
by repeal is a change in the name of the
Act what is needed are very broad
amendments to the taft-hartley Act to
bring it into line with current
conditions and also to take out of it
remove from it those particular sections
which are not fair and which are not
workable in a large measure that should
have been done back in 1948 we who were
trying to get sound Labor Relations
legislation through the taft-hartley Act
in the first instance expected that in
1948 we would finish the job by
correcting the defects in the act
unfortunately the president the United
States thought he had a wonderful
political argument there and a wonderful
political issue and he did all he could
to block it and due to his control over
the members of the Congress the leaders
anyway and his party in the Congress he
was able to prevent any effective
legislation being passed by the Congress
during the period of time from 1948 to
the present that's what's happened I see
as a final brief question sir since you
yourself are running for reelection in
New York how do you think New York will
vote in your race and I'm for General
Eisenhower on - well I'm not going to
predict regarding myself I hope to win I
certainly shall do everything I can if
I'm elected to carry on the work I've
been doing down the Congress and works
the best of my ability and I so
appreciate winning if I can get there
well as far as the state's concerned the
state's going Republican for eisenhower
well thank you very much for being with
us sir the opinions you've heard our
speakers expressed tonight are entirely
their own the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Chronos code
was mr. William Bradford Huie
and mr. Robert B Colburn our
distinguished guests was the honorable
Irving M Ives
United States Senator from New York
next use the millions of Americans will
go to the polls to exercise their right
and privilege as citizens
don't let your vote be lost my friend
for freedom of choice is a very precious
freedom it extends throughout our life
in this great Republic even to the
things we buy and it's to help you make
your choice to give you freedom of
choice in the watch that you buy that we
tell you on this program the facts about
launching it should mean something and
it does mean something that in
competition with the world's best
watches lawn gene is the only watch to
win ten world's fair grand prizes and
twenty eight gold medal Awards it should
mean something and it does mean
something that in competition with the
world's most accurate watches lawn jean
has won countless prizes in competitive
accuracy trials at the great government
observatories so if you wish to choose
for your own or to select as a gift just
about the finest watch made anywhere in
the world the facts about lawn jean
should convince you from personal
experience
millions of discriminating men and women
the world over have made this statement
true no other name on a watch means so
much as launching the world's most
honored watch premier product of the
lawn jean wit nor wats company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character we invite you to
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
long gene promise code the television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
on eight Longy
the honored walk is long gone gene
watches have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece launching the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the long gene with no watch company it's
time for the launching Chronister a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. donald i Roger is an
editor of the New York Herald Tribune
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable John J Sparkman United
States Senator from Alabama the opinions
expressed are necessarily those of the
KERS senator Sparkman among your many
activities in the Senate your chairman
of the committee on small business which
is a mounting problem tonight we'd like
to have you tell us some of the things
you and your committee are doing to help
the small business men first sir would
you be kind enough to tell us what you
consider to be the major problem of the
small business men of America I believe
that right now the major problem
confronting the small business man of
America is that of getting sufficient
materials with which to continue
operating his business is there anything
you or your committee can do to channel
materials to him
we can't channel the materials but we
can certainly keep after the various
agencies that do do that in order to
make certain that small business gets
its fair share now son eternity things
when you talk about small business you
mean a small manufacturer do you not
ordinarily that would be true although
not necessarily true because service
organizations would be small business
just same however they're not confronted
with this problem of materials materials
naturally is a problem confronting
manufacturers and how do you define a
small business what do you think of is a
small business the Defense Department
sets an arbitrary definition of small
business as any business which with its
associates employs not more than 500
persons now can you make a general
statement about this this business now
these small businesses are they
generally suffering at present yes a
great many small businesses are
suffering because since the outbreak of
war in Korea there has been a scarcity
of steel aluminium copper nickel those
have been the principal is any one
section of the country hurt worse than
other sections I don't know that we
could see one section was hurt worse
than another but it's a spotty some
cities are I think let me but yes
undoubtedly that are exactly there are
some some cities defined as surplus
labor areas are there not yes all of
those however are not due to small
business problems for us to says the
automobile cutback in Detroit yes but
don't know about Providence Rhode Island
for instance yes that is one area that I
had in mind a minute ago there it's
primarily the jewellers which are
smokers and things that con yes that's
true now what could you do to help a
jeweler in Providence we believe at the
Defense Department ought to find some
use for them in making a precision
instruments timing instruments fuses and
things of that kind could you give me an
example of where your committee has
helped a certain small business yes
i-i'll go back a little piece I give you
many but since you've got us up in New
England I'll tell you one there
you know in every heel rubber heel of
every shoe there are a certain number of
tax I don't know whether you know that
or not but is true on the head of every
one of those taxes a little tiny washer
yeah uh you can't put your upper heels
on the shoes unless you've got those
washers uh those washers are made by
just two or three small establishments
up here in New England or a year so ago
they got to the point where they
couldn't get any steel with which to
make those little washers and because
they couldn't make the washers the shoe
industry was confronted with a very
serious situation we got busy and got
steel for them to make their washers you
took back again dozens of examples but
you took that steel from some military
operation did you not no we simply saw
that two steel was channeled in there no
no there was plenty of steel it just
simply some mistake had been made and
they didn't get their fair share I own
it they're on our show the other night
mr. Arthur Fleming is the manpower
Commission was here and he told us that
the plans were being made now on the
assumption that this defense emergency
will continue over a period of 10 to 15
years now in and you're thinking of your
committee in the Senate are you making
the same assumption that we have
something like a ten to fifteen year
plan before us I don't think we can
safely make any other assumption let me
say this though it's at the present time
we're building up that doesn't mean if
we're going to continue to build up for
an over a period of 10 or 15 years I
believe the present program calls for
getting tuned up into our maximum
production by July 1st 1954 then we'll
be able to level off and I think that is
what he must have had in mind lasting
over a period of 10 or 12 15 years level
off at peak production you mean at peak
capacity yes not necessarily that we'll
be producing the tanks and guns but
they'll be tooled up to the point that
we can produce them tell me this senator
do you find that the government per se
the administration is sympathetic to
small business or is it dealing mostly
with the larger businesses well I don't
think that to necessarily your
go together yes I think I got a loaded
question I mean no is is the government
cognizant of the problem that the small
business has yes sometimes I think that
some of the agencies are not as keenly
alert to them as they ought to be I'll
tell you what my thought has been it's
simply this that it's so easy and safe
to do business with big business
first of all they have their
representatives there they help work out
everything they have fine records they
know that they're capable of doing it
they've done it in the past and so on
and so forth it it's easier to do
business with them but we believe they
ought to exert a little extra effort in
order to keep this highly essential part
of our national economy by the way
remember this that ninety percent of the
businesses of America are small
businesses senator this is very
interesting but our audience also knows
you is a very influential southern
senator and I'm sure they'd like to have
your views first where do you stand in
the political firmament are you a a
southern new dealer do you think of
yourself as being a New Deal senator no
no I don't think of myself as being a
New Deal senator I've always felt that I
was rather independent and I think most
of the southerners are now where do you
stand in the fight now the presidential
fight are you for Senator Russell for
the presidential nomination the Alabama
delegation supported senator Russell in
the 1948 convention in Philadelphia we
think very highly of senator Russell I
know of no one that I would rather
support than he and and do you take the
traditional southern position on on
civil rights legislation also called
civil rights legislation I do suppose
General Eisenhower becomes a Republican
nominee do you have any predictions on
the outcome of the vote in the South I
would say this it's hard for me to
envision the South voting for anybody
under the Republican emblem yes you know
there's a tradition down
in Alabama we have the crewing rooster
as our symbol and people when they go to
the polls in November don't mail them go
then but when they do go they'd like to
make their cross under that rooster it's
going to be pretty hard to get them to
make the cross under an elephant
regardless of who's up on that ticket
but let me say this Durrell Eisenhower
is very very popular in the south
more popular than any other Republican
candidate you I think that's true yes I
think that's true you are also a
powerful member of the banking and
currency committee senator and our
audience has heard a great deal about
the reconstruction Finance Corporation
now do you think that all of the
corruption has been cleared up there I
believe that it has I think senator
Fulbright in his subcommittee did an
excellent job in digging into the RFC
and since that time there's been a
reorganization of it along the line that
Senator Fulbright himself suggested we
have a single administrator we just the
Senate has just confirmed a new one and
I believe he's going to do a good job
and on the subject of taxes which a
great many people are thinking of about
this time where do you stand
are you believe economy minded this year
do you want to cut the budget yes I do
would you cut foreign aid
I think foreign aid let me put it this
way I'm on the Foreign Relations
Committee that bill will come before us
I know that we will examine it most
carefully and the last year we cut it a
little more than a billion dollars I
should not be surprised to see it cuts
on this year also what is your
prediction for the cut on the overall
budget
I'm also only Joint Economic Committee
and for the last two or three weeks
we've been wrestling with that very
problem I suppose it's all right for me
to say that our report will probably
come out tomorrow morning and we're
going to recommend that every effort be
made to bring the budget into balance
and to do that that would be what well
because that's hard to tell but it
probably would entail a
in the budget of something like seven or
eight billion dollars maybe even as much
as ten billion how much would you cut
from foreign aid under this and let me
put it this way I'm on the committee to
pass on it I don't have prejudge it if I
had to make a rough guess I would guess
that billion dollars at least would be
cut out of foreign aid and are you in
are you do you believe in balanced
budget yourself yes very strongly I
think that an unbalanced economy with
the inflationary pressures that are
generated as a result of it could give
us a tremendous a lot of trouble and
what do you think about taxes are you in
favor of cutting taxes as soon as
possible oh yes but I don't know that's
good we're not going to be able to cut
them for a couple of years anyhow so I
thought you go ask me if I'm going to be
in favor of raising taxes that's what
most the talk is about now I'm not in
favor for increasing taxes you're not in
favor of increasing them you think that
they'll remain about where they are for
at least another two years yes I see no
chance of lowering the blow under two
years I'm sure that our audience is very
much appreciated your views tonight
thank you for being with us sir the
editorial board for this edition of the
long gene Khurana scope was mr. William
Bradford Huie and mr. Donald I Rodgers
our distinguished guests was the
honorable John J Sparkman United States
Senator from Alabama
you heard it said of course most people
know the price of everything and the
value of nothing now that's just not
true certainly not for long gene watches
for more people know the value of a lone
gene watch than its price do you know
for instance that there are many models
of the world's most honored watch which
sell for as little as seventy one fifty
so if you pay seventy one fifty or more
per watch you're paying the price of a
lone gene the world's most honored watch
why not insist on getting a long gene
honored for excellence and elegance by
ten world's fair grand prizes and twenty
eight gold medals honored for accuracy
by innumerable honors from the great
government observatories honored for
honesty in fields of precise timing in
sports aviation exploration and science
so if you wish to preach is a very fine
watch either for yourself or as a gift
look for the value in the watch you buy
and let your choice the long gene the
world's most honored watch premiere
product of the long gene with nor watch
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
this is Frank night again inviting you
to be with us every Monday Wednesday and
Friday evening at this same time for the
long gene Cronus cope a television
journal of the important issues of the
our broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for lawn gene
wit nor watches
it's time for the launching promise
though a television journal of the
important issues of the hour
brought to you every Monday Wednesday
and Friday a presentation of the laun
gene with snore what's company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Cronus cope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. donald i rogers an
editor of the new york herald tribune
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the Honorable Joseph R McCarthy
United States Senator from Wisconsin the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers Senator McCarthy are
probably the most controversial figure
on the American political scene McCarthy
and McCarthyism were well-known words
I'm sure our audience is very much
interested in your political career so
suppose we start right out sir tell us
about the campaign in Wisconsin you're
running for re-election I believe okay I
can't tell you too much about mr. Rogers
except I heard the new man announced
today it will be a tough close contest I
think in the primary in the primary yes
a Republican opponent I've got three or
four Republican opponents and I heard
now I hope that I'm correct in this I
heard that a new man Lana Schmidt
announced today this is the man who ran
for governor is it not
he went for governor two years ago and
ran up a sizeable hopes if mr. Schmidt
an effective campaigner his yeah he is
an effective campaign and you regard mr.
Smith if he's running as you're perhaps
most dangerous opponent I wouldn't want
to insult the other young men who are
running by saying they were not
dangerous I see and then you say that
the primary fight will be serious what
kind of primary do
an open primary to both Democrats and
Republicans vote in the Republican
primary we have an unusual situation in
Wisconsin mr. Ewing the Democrats can
all evoke the Republican primary if they
care to and the Republicans of course
could vote in the Democratic primary as
I cared too that means that if the
Democrats could induce enough of their
democratic over the Republican primary
and vote against me it could make it
very rough but no Hellinger's for
McCarthyism couldn't it well of course I
should say that I think that's held yet
about as many Democrat votes out there
is any other candidate we get some
awfully good Democrats in Wisconsin is
this going to be one of those campaigns
that considerable amounts of money will
be spent from outside the state do you
expect the money will be spent there
sent into Wisconsin to try to help
defeat you there is a fortune being sent
and Wisconsin already in fact I think
there's the more campaign literature put
out by my opposition up to this time and
the normally has been during the entire
campaign on top of that in addition to
that I should say there's a book coming
out being written by one of drew
Pearson's man the man from the New York
Post originally they were going to call
up the hairy ape for the missing link I
guess the new name they have for it is a
cemetery and the ISM or something like
that it'll be all the usual smear by
anyway and it's going to be it's going
to be a unpleasant campaign well
speaking of support from out of the
state you have been supported or
endorsed by such gentlemen as Gerald L K
Smith and Upton close do you accept
their supports are you do you welcome it
I don't think I have been endorsed or
supported by Gerald Smith they're up and
close not not that I know of today but
let me say this I am NOT going to pass
upon any man no matter party's
reputation ads I know certain men have
reputations being anti-semitic and I'm
sure that no one can point to anything
in my background to show that I am anti
any particular group I had here none of
my votes nothing else I have here
Senator McCarthy a publication called
headlines
once behind them another publication
called conspiracy the Philip drool case
are you familiar with these not with the
publication strategies they mention your
name in here endorsing you and they also
mention that General Eisenhower is part
of a Semitic plot to overthrow the world
it's part of the literature that's
circulating about you know do you know
about these publications no I don't may
I say that whether Eisenhower or Taft is
nominated in either event I think we'll
have a good nominee and by saying
Eisenhower Taft I don't want to exclude
the possibility of another great
American like General MacArthur or get
some other good candidates but I'm not
at all disturbed about the Americanism
the loyalty of any of the front-running
candidates we have good Americans I
think they're good Republicans do only
on the national scene and I'm a man said
in any any publication which intimates
that there's anything American but any
of our front-running candidates he was
mistaken putting it my way hey all of
our candidates in your opinion are solid
American gentlemen all of those
front-running candidates all of those
that have been mentioned in connection
with these publications which endorsed
you and opposed general eisenhower you
do not believe should be circulated
there I don't know what's in that
publication mr. Rogers all I can say is
that I've been taking no part in the
presidential race
I've been fully satisfied that
regardless of which one of the men
nominated he'll be a good candidate and
we've got a bunch of good delegates at
Chicago good Americans I won't be afraid
to support him to the hilt I intend to
do that regardless of who's nominated on
the Republican ticket on it well
senator now speaking of campaigns do you
expect the campaign outside of Wisconsin
between November
mr. human I
some heavy obligations to other senators
men who have come to my age when things
look blackest in this fight against
communists and government some of them
are in the so-called marginal states if
they think they're having difficulty in
their Senate race if they think that I
can help them I will come into their
states I may say this that if the
Republicans should take over the Senate
I happen to be the ranking member on the
investigating committee that means that
McCarthy would become chairman of the
Senate investigating committee and if he
does I'll make you one promise that
Leavenworth won't hold them but really
you're going to use the same tactics
that you have used right iliza oh no and
you said the same tactics to see if you
have a committee the power to subpoena
investigators you don't use the same
tactics you use when you have no no
committee no party subpoena we've got to
dig and root out the Communists and the
crooks and those are bad for America
yeah where you go you have a committee
so that you have a power of subpoena you
can get the records and if we have a
Republican president we'll be able to
get those records I'm sure it will be a
less spectacular fight but much more
effective you see it's it's difficult
when you're all alone with the entire
power this federal bureaucracy against
you difficult to dig money even if that
you see we have exposed governor the
government eleven of those I originally
named some what some have been convicted
others before the grand jury but all out
of the government under the loyalty
program
I know patrician I know you do to that
mr. Lattimore has been requested not to
leave the country miss mr. Latimer was
not one of the eleven because he was no
longer in the government had been used
as an advisor but I didn't count him
mostly eleven senator now he's not being
used along you you spoke of it may I say
something a further answer to mr. Rogers
comment the State Department has been
taking credit for the band upon
Latimore's leaving the country that is
just improper because the State
Department did not initiate that ban
okay it is a Justice Department the
Justice Department either phoned or
wrote mr. sheply division in the visa
division and said close the Canadian
borders close the Mexican borders close
the Atlantic close the Pacific to own
Lattimore don't let him leave the
country that's not a result of our I
know Attorney General I don't know I the
previous attorney general McGrath was a
good friend of mine
I break happy to see the new Attorney
General apparently going about his job
in a good serious fashion you thought of
me I make I've just done a 10 second if
I were making predictions I would make
this prediction tonight that is this the
State Department we will use every bit
of power at their disposal to try and
get Owen Lattimore out of this country
within the next two or three months
you must have reasons for saying that
there are very good reasons and when I
suggest that you just watch what happens
over the next few weeks and few months
and understand why now let me understand
these two predictions that you've made
senator they sound very important to me
you are predicting for our viewers that
within the next few weeks the State
Department will use its influence to get
professor Adam Ward outside the country
that's correct
can you area Weiser
frankly I can't yeah I mean I could but
I for reasons which I'll explain the f
we get off the air I just couldn't do it
and do it here now the other you know
you'll understand why within a matter of
all right I'll answer my Lasker I'll
call our viewers attention to your
prediction than you do list and now the
other thing that I'd like to get very
clear because it sounds important if
you're elected re-elected senator and if
there's a Republican victory this fall
then you will be chairman of the present
what's known as the McCarran Committee
would you know nothing much here in
committee it's the NA known as the
senator hooey committee formerly the
Truman Committee a special Senate
investigating committee I see and you
were also made the prediction that if
you can get control of that committee
that you expect to fill up Leavenworth
and a few more of the federal prisons is
that correct yes I think mister who any
good American in charge of that
investigating committee senator there's
one other you mentioned a book and
there's one book here that we should
call our viewers attention to it's your
book that there's published today I
believe yes
now I in effect what's the what's the
message of this book to the people of
America see those who we called that
book McCarthyism the fight for America
it is a carefully documented history of
the fight to expose communists bad
security risks and the dupes and Stooges
of the Kremlin who have been and still
are in our federal government or
sanitarium yes it is also a quick at I'm
sorry that our time is up I'm sure that
I viewers have appreciated your very
forthright views and thank you for being
with us it thank you
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching crow no scope was mister
William Bradford Huie and mr. Donald I
Rodgers our distinguished guest was the
Honorable Joseph R McCarthy United
States Senator from Wisconsin
the United States Olympic Committee has
chosen long Jean mutters to time all
events for the selection of the United
States Olympic team of 1952 thanks to
the fine financial response of the
public a full team representing
virtually all amateur sports will go to
Helsinki and the members of the team are
selected through competitive trials and
two-time these events lawn jean has
provided some 100 long Jean Olympic
timing watches like this the world's
finest timing watch with accuracy
certified by bulletins from a government
Observatory now because of such
demonstrated accuracy long Jean has
chosen to time championship sports
events the world over the 1952 Olympic
Winter Games the first Pan American
Games and the third Bolivarian Games
laun Jean is official watch for the
contest board of the American Automobile
Association the American powerboat
Association the National Aeronautics Oca
ssin and many many others and it's
because also of the exceptional
trustworthiness and the accuracy that
launching watches like these have that
they're the first choice with
discriminating men and women throughout
the world long jane the world's most
honored watch premiere product of the
laun jean wit nor watch company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene cross code a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lone jean
this is frank night reminding you that
lawn jean and wit nor watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
lawn jean wit nor watches
you